all right guys
what do we got we got
20 20. Jeep Grand Cherokee another one
of these uh Chrysler Gateway cars where
we have a choice
I use a 12 8 cable or
use that um
ADC
2011.
um gotta be honest
this car is very very easy with the 12
8. um
I just popped this panel off
there's a star connector back there uh
tough to get to
I'm assuming I'd probably have to drop
part of the dash whatever I'm certainly
not doing that if they're a quick Google
search it did say
there's a star connector over here under
the passenger dashboard but my opinion
you're gonna see where this 12 8
connector is all I'm doing is pulling
this panel down
sorry about that
that's it right there very easy to
unplug
very easy to get to so I don't see any
reason to use go looking for the star
connector when that's right there so I'm
going to get everything hooked up I'll
be right back
all right so we're back uh
we're gonna
Auto detect here and to be clear what
I've done over here
I'll basically just unplug those two
connectors
from the Gateway
and plug them into my little 12 8
connector
so we'll go Jeep America
a couple of warnings we'll blow by those
let's get the OEM key one two five
button
uh our new key another one from best uh
Key Supply
2020 Cherokee
I will
car off and the ignition on
we'll do ammo status scan
engine ignition on engine off we're good
foreign
we'll check these out
it's a common one you've already seen
that one
certainly doesn't have anything to do
with us programming keys
and we'll check these as well
and we'll go re-pin code
ignition off hazards on
uh it's 10 16. ignition off
hazards on
I might hang out for a second last time
this is really quick but uh
I'll pause it I'll be back
all right so that one took a little
longer than most it's uh
10 19. so we'll just uh quickly record
that just in case two one eight one
we will go add key
no reason to
yes okay
okay
proximity near the center console or the
start start room complete within 60
seconds I've seen a lot of guys do a lot
of different things on these you know
old key I think it's going to ask us to
press unlock repeatedly press unlock
until
uh the Key Programs I guess so here we
go
and again I've seen you guys
up here
up near the push button
my experience a limited experience
I'm not sure if it matters
but eventually
we're just gonna hear the doors unlock
and that'll let us know that this key is
programmed
I just heard a click
says it learned do you want to learn
next key no
they are
a little Escape out of here
the hazards
we will
ditch the Customs key
and test our key
that's it we're done I'll uh test the
other functions report back if if
there's any issues